is the new ipad mini 6 actually worth
500
well today we will talk about everything
that apple didn't mention at their event
both the good things and the bad things
and if you should drop your hard earned
money on this device and if i will be
buying it personally let's start out
with that new design and it's exactly
what i have wanted for years since
basically the 2018 ipad pro came out it
basically looks like that ipad pro or
the new ipad air 4 just a smaller
version now we have a lot of differences
on the display compared to the other
ipads which i'm going to get into the
new one is 8.3 inches compared to 7.9
inches but the bezels are larger on the
sides than this ipad mini 5 which i love
but they are equal all around and of
course you do need somewhere to hold on
so i'm not really upset about that now
on the positive side we still have that
ultra high pixel density 326 pixels per
inch which if you didn't know the ipad
minis actually have the sharpest display
out of any ipad so apple did keep that
but our aspect ratio actually changed
coming from a 16x9 display to a 4.6 by 3
display which sounds really weird and
this is actually an aspect ratio apple
has never used before and it is the
widest screen on any ipad ever they did
that for one particular reason now when
we factor in that change of display size
and aspect ratio we actually lose some
pixels on this and over here so we have
less pixels here but the screen is
taller or longer now what that means is
that this ipad is going to be fantastic
for watching movies because you're going
to have less bars on it and you're just
basically just having that wider display
but when you're holding it this way
it's going to be more like a phone with
a taller display overall you're getting
about 5.5 percent more screen real
estate and even though the screen is
larger the thickness is staying the same
and the ipad actually weighs less than
this one which is really nice and with
that the actual width of the device if
you're holding it vertically is actually
identical meaning that this will be very
comfortable to hold with one hand just
like i've been doing so that is why
apple decided to make the screen a wider
aspect ratio so comfort would stay the
same now because the home button is gone
now because the chin and the little
forehead here is smaller and equal all
around the device is actually not as
tall it's shorter so the device overall
is smaller it is lighter but we have a
larger display which is fantastic now
unfortunately unlike many of the rumors
that we have heard
we did not get a mini led display we
know apple was testing that but probably
because of cost and yield they're not
including it so other than the size and
aspect ratio everything else about the
display is the same the contrast
brightness color accuracy and that's not
a bad thing this was a good display now
of course just like the ipad air 4 we
have the touch id sensor built in to the
top with the power button which is nice
now i wasn't a fan of that on the ipad
just because it was so large you had to
move your hand out of the way this thing
is much smaller so i believe it's easier
to use you just pull your finger up if
you're holding it this way and you can
touch it so it's more convenient and
with that our volume buttons also got
moved to the top as well because now
apple is allowing you to magnetically
attach the apple pencil to to the side
and because it's so small it's actually
shorter than this one you need all of
that space for the apple pencil now
before i tell you what i am personally
most excited about along with
performance so that is not what i'm most
excited about let me tell you guys go
ahead and subscribe down below if you
guys want to see the comparisons against
the ipad mini 5 against the ipad air
maybe even against the ipad pro with the
m1
that will also help us reach our goal of
1 million subscribers we would greatly
appreciate it now what i'm personally
most excited about are the speakers we
finally have stereo speakers on the ipad
mini i love this device for watching
videos i loved it for playing games but
it sucks having the speakers be just on
the bottom or on the right side when
you're holding it this way all the sound
is coming from over here it sucked and
that's all i really wish for if they
just did that as an update maybe a year
ago i would be perfectly happy but now
we have the dual speakers they're set up
in a stairs this week great for watching
videos great for playing games i'm super
excited about that and now on to the
performance of course we have the a15
bionic and let me tell you it is going
to be insane in this ipad now i was
hoping they would put this in there's a
chance they just stick with the a14
because the ipad air 4 has that but no
they didn't and they didn't even use the
slower version of the a15 this thing has
the full blown one from the iphone 13
pros with the 5 core graphics now this
thing is going to be a beast it's going
to be the most powerful tablet other
than the m1 ipad pros it's going to
smoke the ipad air it's going to smoke
other iphones as well it's going to be
crazy now that is because even with the
a14 that had also four graphics courses
just like the iphones the ipad air 4
with the a14 had better graphics
performance because of thermal
throttling it had quite a bit better
performance now this thing is also going
to thermal throttle less than the
iphones and it has a 5 core graphics so
it's going to be insane as far as gaming
performance now even though the tablet
is smaller it is lighter the battery
capacity has stayed the same meaning
that paired with that a15 processor
that's much more efficient than before
the battery life will actually be better
in the real world now as far as cameras
we also have some massive improvements
we have a 12 megapixel camera on the
back now this camera is actually from
the iphone 12 s and we know that because
it's rated 4k 30 frames per second with
extended dynamic range and that's the
same sensor that is on the iphone 10s
after that it ended up shooting 4k 60
with extended dynamic range but with
newer software the newer processor the
images are better and we do also have
smart hdr3 which the iphone 10s does not
get now with that we also have a flash
and that is very convenient for scanning
documents and for other tasks so i'm
glad they added this in they didn't have
to and then we have a huge improvement
on the front i was not expecting apple
to put in their center stage ultra wide
camera on this tablet but they did so if
you're somebody that does web
conferencing you want to play games you
want to record yourself
whatever you want to do with that camera
that is definitely a really nice
improvement and now let's talk about
what apple did not include with the ipad
mini 6 or what we're losing if we
upgrade to that tablet in some of the
downsides well the first one is this
headphone jack it is gone now even
though this device is super thin and the
new one's thickness is practically the
same actually slightly thicker but you
won't notice it and we did have a
headphone jack here nope it is gone so
the only tablet that still has a
headphone jack is their very cheapest
tablet and that is definitely a bummer
now with that you guys see this nice
silver color that is now gone so we have
space gray pink purple and starlight
which is the one that i ordered but we
no longer have the silver or the gold
which kinda is a bubber as well now
thankfully we still have a 20 watt power
adapter included in the box so it's
interesting the apple's making a big
deal about it with the iphones they want
to save you know the planet they want to
be more green but with these devices
they're still including it and these are
much less expensive devices i would
think if they got rid of that they can
make the boxes for these super slim
saving a lot of packaging saving
shipping but nope they are including it
which is handy i guess but one thing
that's not handy is that they did not
include the smart connectors on this
device like we saw in rumors meaning
that you will not be able to have a
really nice keyboard to use with this
which is i think is okay this is a
pretty small device to use a keyboard
for and of course there are third-party
bluetooth options just not one of that
doesn't need to be charged and has no
latency and possibly a trackpad now with
that let's talk about 5g because they
did add 5g onto this device now this
year if you want lte it costs more
instead of 130 bucks it's 150 so that is
more expensive and with that it does not
support millimeter wave it just supports
sub six so you're not getting the full
performance of 5g like you will with the
ipad pro on the plus side there are
really nice offers from carriers so if
you're willing to sign up for a contract
and keep buying a fairly decent data
package you can get all of that money
back maybe even some more just make sure
you guys read through the fine print and
you're okay with everything that you're
signing up for now of course we do have
that price increase of a hundred dollars
we're going from 400 which was already a
lot for a small compact tablet now to
500 that is a big price increase is it
worth the money well it's really up to
you guys you guys heard everything that
you got all of the updates to me it does
suck that they're raising the price i do
think it's worth it i think all the
camera upgrades the front the back the
flash the a15 top-line performance with
the best version of that chip the better
display and of course usb type c that
comes with this redesign that part of it
is massive i think this is a killer
tablet those dual speakers man i'm
excited for that
so i think it's worth the price if you
want a tablet this size i think it's
going to be absolutely killer
the one biggest downside to me
personally my biggest complaint is the
storage it still comes with 64 gigs base
and it's weird because with the iphone
13 they said 64 is not enough we're
giving you 128 for the same price we're
here we're paying 100 more in the store
just staying there now not only that
that's not the worst part of it which
does suck
if you want more you have to spend at
least 150 dollars more to go up to 256
which for me that's way too much i'm
never going to use that amount with
phones for years now they allowed you to
pay 50 more in order to jump from 64 to
128 why did they not give us this option
why could i not pay 50 bucks more 550
and get 128 gig no i have to spend 150
more now and get way too much storage on
top of paying 100 more for the tablet
itself that is the biggest bummer that
is why i just bought the base one
i'm gonna rely on icloud be a little bit
more careful with storage i don't want
to spend that much on a small device and
then just have that wasted space but
overall this is the update that i've
been waiting years for the new design
apple pencil on the side all of the
other updates i mentioned i'm super
excited overall if you can stomach the
extra price point with that storage i
think this is going to be a killer
device that you're going to absolutely
love or if you're buying it for your
kids which i know my kids are going to
use this thing all the time they're
going to love it as well so thank you
guys for watching once again you guys
can click that subscribe button above if
you guys want to help us reach our goal
of a million subscribers and see the
comparisons that we're going to be doing
check out one of those great videos over
there this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]